breaking boundaries makes the world of
Awesome a little more awesome so as you
may or may not have heard the theme song
to civilization for the video game
titled Baba yet to follow you do you do
you know the song was nominated for a
Grammy and it just won that's right a
video game song won a Grammy something
that makes the world a little more
awesome if you haven't heard the song
yet I'll put the link below or put an
annotation right there or something it's
like The Lion King meets ancient African
civilizations which I'm pretty sure that
was exactly what the composer was going
for and the reason I'm psyched about
this is because this isn't the only
video game song has been deserving of an
award play Metal Gear Solid and the
theme to uncharted drake's fortune got
me to play the game a decision i do not
regret at all long story short epic
video games have epic soundtracks and
those are words to live by I felt that
video game music should be recognized
for the art that it is for years so I'm
glad it finally is and that being said
have you played civilization 4 have you
heard the theme if not again check it
out below comment below what do you
think about this video game music
getting nominated and winning a Grammy
hopefully it's just step one of like 90
Final Fantasy 6 who has a soundtrack
yeah short video for you guys but I felt
it was worth mentioning because the
world is a little more badass and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more or you like video game music
then click right here to see more